hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is time for the monday morning
podcast for monday
april 12th monday april to monday
april 12th sorry i'm yelling 2
000 and uh 21.
now i'm gonna be perfectly honest with
you i am recording this
the day before because in a couple of
[ __ ]
hours i'm going out i'm making the lamp
vibrate over here with my screaming i'm
going i'm getting my
second shot of unsafe he will be
complicit uncertain thoughts
i'm getting uh the second shot of the
pfizer now
i have found that some people get a
little sick
some people get a lot sick and some
people
don't get sick at all so what i'm
thinking
is it's you know how i was raised that
all comes down to what kind of man you
are
and i know everybody is different and
everybody's brave and everybody's a
[ __ ] star
you know
you know unless you're a white guy
that's successful then you somehow you
know
you must have done something [ __ ]
evil um
diddled somebody or whatever that's sort
of the narrative right now
you know not defending white guys but
also not vilifying all of them you know
kind of being an adult
and you know treating everybody like an
individual like these [ __ ] crazy
lefties act like they do but they don't
really
um oh speaking of which well i will get
to that in a second oh jesus i almost
forgot that i almost forgot what i was
going to talk about there
um so uh
anyway i think that you know i'm just
i'm hydrating there
i took a little vitamin c pill i'm
[ __ ] stoned sober i got great
sleep last night you know when you sleep
so deep you have like
[ __ ] up dreams it's probably because i
had an oreo cookie shake with [ __ ]
whipped cream on top that's like my
[ __ ] bourbon
and cigars now once a [ __ ] week i act
like some freckled
[ __ ] redheaded [ __ ] from the 1950s
who just finished his paper route
and
i go down to the soda fountain i get
myself a shake
[ __ ] you it's all i got left man
that's all i got left um but i love it i
love being stoned [ __ ] sober
until about oh 7 30 at night and then
just those last five [ __ ] hours of
the night are
not five hours like four or whatever
it's not even that
my kids wear me out so i'm usually
asleep by 11.
so if i can just you know the last four
and a half hours oh that's still four
and a half hours huh yeah [ __ ]
if i can just get through that right
i'm usually good so anyway i'm i'm going
to uh
drinking a bunch of water here just
going to be hydrated
and everything i did go on a [ __ ] big
hike yesterday like a [ __ ] idiot
because
um with therapy i'm now jesus he's
dropping stuff here
i've learned that i i work too hard
uh not that i work too hard i'm working
because of
[ __ ] i was [ __ ] avoiding so i'm
trying to face that [ __ ] so i've now
decided
that i'm gonna have one day a week right
one day a week where i just don't do
[ __ ] i got one day where i'm not [ __ ]
doing [ __ ]
you know just like the lord right he
made the earth
in six days which is why it's so [ __ ]
up because he kind of rushed the job
you know like he already had something
else to do guy created the whole [ __ ]
universe in six [ __ ] goddamn days
puts his feet up on the seventh day oh
did you notice the pedophiles oh yeah
sorry about that you know whatever
deal with it um
anyways uh yeah so
what i'm finding is when i don't have
anything to do i will still fill the day
up
oh i don't have anything to do i'm gonna
play drums i'm gonna go on a hike i'm
[ __ ] yeah
i'm like a lunatic so i did do that
yesterday
and uh i just went on a hike i didn't
stretch or anything i just [ __ ] went
out and i woke up today
feeling like [ __ ] earl campbell after
he played the steelers
so i had to take an epson salt bath
just going on a hike that's just you
know it's how old i am now it's just
what it is it is
hey it is what it is so um then i was
like you [ __ ] idiot you're getting
the second vaccine shot
and you're you're already putting this
pressure on yourself that if you get
sick you're not a man
so um i just been drinking water and uh
you know whatever we'll see what happens
so but i think it's a combination
everything it's also how you
you know just how it affects you and
your dna [ __ ]
uh but then i also think i would say
that that's probably 30
of it and the other 70 is basically how
much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you are
you know there's some people they get a
cold and they just sort of shake it off
and continue their life and then there's
other people
that are you know actually smart they
they kind of shut things down
and rest up you know if you're doing
that that's smart but if you're the
person who acts like you now have ebola
you know those people they just get a
[ __ ] cold
and they think they need to go to the
doctor i think those people
affect are sort of affecting you know
people talking about like that second
vaccine shot
how they feel because i know somebody
who works out like a maniac
and is in really great condition and she
got the johnson and johnson
you know two for one bing bang boom
you're done and she didn't even get sick
so um i don't know i'm kind of looking
at that i kind of look at like the way
that i look at like golf
how golf so many of the people that play
it are just not athletes
so this idea of how difficult the game
is
obviously playing it at the level that
these guys at the masters are playing it
which i'll get into in a minute i'm
really enjoying watching that this year
um playing at a pro level is [ __ ]
incredible
you know you know being a scratch golfer
is incredible but all those people that
are trying to break 100 break 90
80 it's just like what sports have you
excelled in
there's so many people out there like
people who suck at sports are not going
to go down
to venice beach and get in a pickup
basketball game they're not going to
play touch football
then they just they don't play sports
but this the thing about golf
i know i've said this is people are
there
because they they're in an unhappy
marriage they're there because they want
to make connections
you know and they buy the whole stupid
outfit and and that that's what this
golf is the only [ __ ] sport
where they literally change the
equipment
to try and they adjust the equipment to
how bad a golfer you are
if you have a hook or a slice they will
give you a club where you don't have to
change your [ __ ] swing
the club does it for you and as i've
maintained
during all of my rants about golf is
that they have not redesigned the
football
you know so someone who can't throw the
thing can now throw a [ __ ] tight
spiral that's my thing
you'll hit it longer and straighter with
this club face
i don't have to do any work myself nope
nothing let the club do it for you
um i this goes back to the virus thing
where i just think that like those
[ __ ] people
are dragging the curve down so um
i'm anticipating i'm gonna feel like a
little bit under the weather but other
than that i think i'm gonna be fine
and uh my wife's already giving me [ __ ]
because i'm
she goes okay now you you're getting the
shot today so on monday you can't
do anything so i'm like fine i'd love to
have a day off great
and i go i i really think i'm going to
be fine
i go you know i really just think a lot
of people they're just [ __ ] [ __ ]
like anything that [ __ ] happens it is
it's just like chicken little like the
[ __ ] skies falling
right and she's just immediately going
like you know bill
you know a lot of people they're they're
different they're just not wired the way
you're wired
and then i realized like
that she hasn't gotten her second shot
yet so by me saying that i'm
putting pressure on her to
not be like whining the next day so i
was like all right i get it i get it all
right
sorry you know what's gonna happen i bet
i bet she doesn't get sick at all and i
bet i'm gonna be going like oh my god
you gotta take me to the hospital
um so anyway that's
that's what i'm up to uh i did a couple
of really really fun shows i did a show
uh in a parking lot outside of a gym
because that's where we're at as we wait
for people the smart people to go out
and get vaccinated
or the sheeple as the people
as they say on the internet that listen
they don't listen to doctors but they
listen to their friend who googled
something
on the internet like the internet is
like you know
there's no rules of libel or slander on
the internet you can post whatever you
want and say that it's true
just know that it's probably not a good
place to go to get information
um yeah the next thing you know you're
dressed like a buffalo and you're
running into the capitol with no shirt
on and you face painted like that's what
happens when you go on the internet and
you if you start googling [ __ ] that
could that can happen to you
you know then i'm not [ __ ] on that
guy that guy came
so close to being a face on our money
for the next 200 [ __ ] years he was
right [ __ ] there and then it all fell
apart so you got to tip your [ __ ]
buffalo hat to him
for for having the balls to go after a
dream i never get mad at that
um anyway
so and then the next night i went down
and i returned to that i didn't even
know it was the same gig because they
said it was hermosa beach if they said
seal beach i'd be like wait a minute is
this this same [ __ ] place
um that i went you know a while back
where they were like yeah we don't have
covid down here because of the sea
breeze or whatever the [ __ ] they were
saying
and i went down there it was the same
[ __ ] place but i didn't run into that
lady um
but everybody this time down there was
wearing masks which was cool
you know there was still the people that
like i just don't get the person who
wears the mask and then like goes to
talk to you
pulls the mask down when they go to talk
and leans towards you it's just like
how [ __ ] dumb oh just take the mask
off you're [ __ ] dope
[ __ ] dopes and i'm also seeing a lot
of people
like they got one shot and now they're
like yeah i've been vaccinated or people
just saying i've been vaccinated and
they're just walking around
without a [ __ ] mask on it's just like
the level
of [ __ ] selfish
[ __ ] behavior it's just [ __ ]
unbelievable
it's um it's um i will never get over uh
just like all it took to derail
everybody who walks around talks about
how tough they are is that they had to
put on a mask and they just
couldn't [ __ ] do it i mean i'm
breathing my own breath
it's dangerous
acting like it was carbon monoxide
acting like no oxygen was getting in
there and you're going to pass out it's
like no
you didn't want to do it because it was
inconvenient to you because you
are an individual you know while they
all go support the troops america
love it or leave it and all that and
then the pandemic happens and it's all
just like
this is all about me i love that all
these [ __ ] red state [ __ ] started
[ __ ] acting like lefty celebrities
they got their own [ __ ] sitcom
i am not coming out of my dressing room
until every all of my demands are met
did you see that douche bag they told
him put a mask on in a store and he had
like
a gallon of milk and he [ __ ] spiked
it like gronkowski in the store
and walked out literally like a [ __ ]
two-year-old
because he couldn't wear a mask for
[ __ ] 11 minutes to go in and shop for
groceries
unfucking believable we'll never never
never [ __ ] get i shouldn't just put
that on people in red states because i
saw a lot of blueys out here doing the
same [ __ ] thing
however i did want to talk about this as
far as like uh
cause this thing i'm gonna get my
[ __ ] vaccine second one
today and then you know technically i
think after a couple weeks like i won't
have to wear a mask but i'll still wear
one just to not make other people
uncomfortable
thinking i'm just some [ __ ] mouth
breathing dope breathing all over
um all right that's what a hero i am
look at me building myself up
it's easy thing to do when you do your
podcast without a guest you know you
don't get questioned
um all right so plowing ahead here
uh so i did the second show at
hermosa which was great there was like
three people that were like
you know john bonham lev leveled drunk
in the crowd and they were
running their yaps which is a little was
a little annoying but
the payoff came in the end when one of
them literally
did a face plant in the front row
it was awesome and he was he went down
and
it like i couldn't see i couldn't see
him
hit because the way the stage was he
just disappeared he was right in the
front row just
fell down i saw it out of the corner of
my eye and then i looked at the sober
people in that section those poor people
who were trying to listen to my act
instead of this idiot
commenting on everything i was saying
and i was like did he just fall down and
they'd just go like yeah he did
and then like it took i swear to god it
took like 40 seconds
before he resurfaced and he had his hand
his head he was trying to push himself
back up on the chair and i was saying i
was always a fan of the three stooges so
it was worth it he was a harmless guy
he was a nice guy he just was [ __ ]
shit-faced and you know what it was
friday night on a beach
and i was performing outside so you know
what are you going to do right what are
you going to do
um it was a it was a it was a really uh
it was a good time but uh just for all
you guys who think that like la is like
super liberal and [ __ ] uh
yeah that was la and it was on the beach
bruh
and like the next day i i wish i knew
during the show because i would have
made fun of them but the next day like i
think today
or yesterday maybe they were having a
clan rally
clan rally yeah the ultimate white
privilege
clan rally you can be part of that hate
group terrorist group
and you are not considered a terrorist
they actually my wife went on their
website they were saying how they're not
a terrorist group
no we're all about love we just love
white people
so anyway i have a bunch of questions
for
the clan when you join the clan um
and you pay your membership do you get
do you get the sheets
with with the membership or is it like
the marines in the ar in the air force
in
the armed services now we actually have
to pay for your uniform too
and also uh has the uniform slightly
changed over the years
do you have a favorite era of clan
uniforms
was there a redneck like michelin ness
that if you want to go old school you
could get like a clan hoodie from like
the 1920s just just out of curiosity
um anyways
plowing ahead i feel bad for those
people
you know just living on one little patch
of grass
in this whole big world why would you do
that to yourself
i ain't eating no food unless it's white
food
all right that's how you want to do it
um anyway but i've been watching the
masters
uh all the clan people just perked up
master i liked it i liked it i liked the
way it sounds um
i've been watching that and uh
i actually watched it yesterday and
there's this
japanese dude who just [ __ ]
took over just [ __ ] took over
yesterday
he wasn't i don't know because i came in
so late and the names not only are all
different
they're uh zelotaurus there's another
guy
s-c-h-a-u-f-f-e-l-e
i mean jesus christ
chapley shafili um
then there's leashman some guy rose or
whatever but like this guy
matsuyama i'm saying that right hideki
matsuyama this is like [ __ ] hockey
now like
i can't pronounce any of the [ __ ]
names hideki matsu
matsuyama was tied for the lead
at seven under and i think he was on
like the 14th hole
and then just he just went on a tear
and birdied like four of the last five
holes or something like that
and uh is now 11 under
going into uh the final day here
you got four guys tied zala torres shall
if he uh leishman and rose it's seven
under now obviously you guys all know
what happened so i'm really looking
forward to watching that and as i sat
down to do this podcast
my uh boston red sox were playing the uh
baltimore orioles who i've always loved
because i loved uh
that guy i think he might have passed
away the bearded dude used to stand on
the
on the dugout and spell out oh
r-i-o-l-e-s
orioles i always thought that was so
cool and i loved earl weaver
screaming at the umpires and all of that
[ __ ] i loved eddie murray
jim palmer um
i just i was just loved that franchise
and they were always really really good
when i was growing up they just had
always had great teams
and so i always respected him um
but anyway you know we were on and for
some reason the mlb package
works in the house but i get in the
garage here in my office
uh it said that i didn't have the
package
so i just said [ __ ] it so i tried to
order it and i call up
and they're doing the dumb [ __ ] you know
where the automated thing is trying to
act like it's a person and you know it
isn't
and like hmm hang on a second and then
they have those keyboard sounds
it's always it's the same keyboard sound
every single time like
like who is the [ __ ] corporate douche
that made me made that that thought that
is such
not a human being that thinks that that
that is a comforting thing for me
the whole [ __ ] thing is insulting i'm
talking to a computer
it should just just make it sound like a
computer hello welcome to direct tv
computer says them
what is your name so i go through the
whole [ __ ]
the name on it the [ __ ] phone number
all of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it always the same thing always
[ __ ] happens
the stupid automatic thing can't help me
and then some guy from [ __ ] india
comes on the phone and
acts like his name is john
and i always call them by their name a
bunch of time hello john how are you
yes hello my name is john it's not john
just say your real [ __ ] name
how racist do you think i am that if you
actually tell me what your real name is
it's gonna sound too ethnic you know
what because that probably happened so
now
he has to act like his [ __ ] name is
john i have to act like that [ __ ]
automated
thing was helping me and we both have to
act like we're happy with our lives in
this moment the whole [ __ ] thing is
so goddamn phony
so then they get on there who's the
[ __ ] thing under
i tell them who it's under you know do
the whole [ __ ] thing i give them the
phone number all of that [ __ ] and then
they're like do you know your password
no i don't
all right for your security purposes let
me ask you a question and they're like
what's your wife's favorite restaurant
it's like i don't know all of them
what's the most expensive restaurant in
my general [ __ ] area
that one so i couldn't answer that one
and it's like isn't it enough that i
gave you the name and the [ __ ] phone
number and then he goes
well you know just to let you know that
your security is our number one priority
over here and it's like
no it isn't john
it isn't john first of all you started
this relationship with a lie
telling me your [ __ ] name is john
and do you know john while i was waiting
to talk to you
the recording said that if if
i order this sports package it's going
to automatically renew
every year and if i want to cancel it i
have to cancel it before the season
starts
and you're saying that my that your
number one priority is my is my security
isn't
money is the number one security
no it's the number one it's your number
one what the [ __ ] am i saying
it's your number one priority
because you know a lot of people are
gonna sleep on it and the [ __ ] the
the season's gonna start and then
they're gonna call up to cancel and then
you have the loophole to say it's too
late
and then of course i know i i know the
back door is all i have to then say is
like well then [ __ ] it cancel my directv
okay we're gonna make an exception don't
act like you're doing a favor
i cracked your code i know what it is
you're all about the [ __ ] money
so i couldn't answer the restaurant i
couldn't answer the thing i couldn't
answer any of these [ __ ] goddamn
questions
and i just say to the guy i go all right
you know what i'm old enough to realize
this isn't going to get to where i want
to be so just
have a nice day goodbye and i hang up on
the guy and then what does he do
after all he's yeah yeah [ __ ] he
[ __ ] calls me right back
like a hot chick that discovered that i
no longer give a [ __ ] about her you know
when that happens and then all of a
sudden they come up to you like some
stray cat that he gave milk to
he had the [ __ ] balls to call me back
so i didn't even [ __ ] answer it
you know what you know what there's
certain things when you're married you
just have to realize
like you know what this is a job for my
wife
she's good at this [ __ ] right you need
the trash barrels taken out you need
them brought in
they smell like [ __ ] ass and you need
them washed out
that's my job right if you got to call
up directv
and and you need passwords and people's
favorite restaurants that's when you
have to go to your wife and i and i
and i [ __ ] up and you know
all i got out of that phone call is i
hope that in a
you know in a world sometime soon the
guy whatever his name is is not gonna
have to get on the phone and [ __ ]
tell me that his name is john
i used to tease those guys and i
realized like why am i going after them
the people i really want to yell at is
some [ __ ] stuff shirt
that lives over here probably has like
some [ __ ] offshore accounts
and phony companies that build from
another phony company it goes all around
the [ __ ] islands right and then comes
back to him and then he doesn't pay
taxes that's the guy i want to [ __ ]
yell at
not some poor bastard that's got to talk
to some hot head like me
he's been talking to a computer that's
been pretending to [ __ ] type
then we'll make the typing sound and
then the person on the other end will be
feel like they're talking to a person
you know i don't know i always have to
put it on mute and then say what i want
to to the robot because if i call the
robot a [ __ ]
it'll be like i'm sorry i don't
understand what you just said
and then you have to start over again
becomes a big pain in the ass
um anyway
so you wouldn't know that i'm actually
happier than i've ever been
i really am i really am and i'm getting
along great with my wife
and just once a week we just we just
go out on a date we hang out and we just
have the best [ __ ] time
and laugh our asses off the way we used
to actually wanted to bring her on the
podcast and i've missed having her on
the podcast
because i love when she comes on and she
gives me [ __ ] and all of that and it's
just we got the kids now so it's like
difficult
because i want to have her on now but my
son is taking a nap so she has to be
watching him blah blah blah blah blah
but
um a thursday afternoon i'm gonna i have
to literally have to have her come on as
like a special guest now it's crazy
so um but obviously the trade-off
is worth it so let me see if my reads or
advertising have come in yet um
hey is it you guys like me is it weird
that the only golf tournament you can
get into
during the year is um
is the uh is the masters i don't know
why that is that's just like the only
one that i can get into
i but i i think i could get into the
british open
is that what they call it even though it
takes place in scotland
you know and they came up with it you
know
whatever the [ __ ] they call it maybe
they don't call it the british open
that's just me being an idiot but um
i uh oh good i got my content here for
the week
thought i had the filibuster here um
i should try to watch one of those wire
to wire but i can never get into like
the pga
in the u.s open
um but i've always there's been
something about golf i've just always in
much as i make fun of the sports
golf it's kind of like star wars when i
made fun of star wars but i didn't
really
seriously hate it i just knew that
people were really into it so i make fun
of it just what you do is a comic you
see people enjoying [ __ ] and then you
[ __ ] [ __ ] on it
because you're secretly not a happy
person i mean that's what that's
basically the formula
so um i'll tell you watching it
yesterday
the shape that golfers are in now i mean
they make me want to work out
they [ __ ] lean and mean a lot of them
i miss the fat golfers
it was something that i always loved
about golf bowling pool
all of those like uh
you know i don't know
fringe sports i guess you'd call them
like that's that big debate like what
makes something a sport
and for me it was always somebody
standing across from you
trying to stop you trying to prevent you
from doing whatever physical endeavor
that you were doing
um you know what i mean
like like the thing about golf is it's
just
you walking up to it to the ball
and hitting it i understand believe me
that just you are left alone with your
own thoughts
as someone who has a [ __ ] thundering
lightning between his ears
half the [ __ ] day i understand that
that is a very difficult thing to do
right but so is baking you know that
doesn't make it a sport there's a lot of
difficult things to do
changing the [ __ ] uh the timing
change on an engine you got to take the
whole that's a [ __ ] difficult thing
to do it's not a sport
you know now if you had a wrench and
there was someone between you and that
engine block
they're trying to tackle you or [ __ ]
screaming at you and all of that [ __ ]
yeah then i would say that's a sport
um i think they're they are
athletic activities
because it involves you know
coordination i would say that right that
opens up
all other canon words whatever whether
there's sports or not i don't give a
[ __ ] i enjoy watching like i
call sit down and [ __ ] watch bowling
i love it i loved i loved and i just
liked that you could do those activities
and be completely
[ __ ] out of shape and i also like
like that you know golfing and
bowling and shooting pool we're done
while getting [ __ ] up drinking and
smoking and all of that [ __ ]
it was just this unhealthy lifestyle
while you were getting in some you know
physical activity like throwing darts
you know so you had like a shredded
elbow
but the rest of you look like a [ __ ]
a yax bladder
whatever whatever the [ __ ] that looks
like um
just picture that [ __ ] like a giant
liver that's been hollowed
out um but
like the the fat golfer is gone like
there was one guy who was
in in the leader and he was just really
like mushy
he wasn't obese but he was just mushy
you know his chest was you know his
stomach was holding up his [ __ ]
titties and it's just like
you know there's like a shame to it now
you know i respected him because he was
still wearing a tight
shirt um but like
you got to be thinking now with all of
these [ __ ] like
golfers that are in like you know
shredded shape
you know wiry sort of shape
that at the very least they're gonna
have an advantage
because they're not lugging around an
extra 30 pounds and then secondly you
know what i mean
you finish the 18th hole you want to
walk off you know meet a couple of
ladies you know if you're coming up
there with sweaty man tits
you know women can look past that if
you're making money
but if there's other guys coming in and
they got pecs they don't got titties
like
you're gonna lose right
so i think that's a good thing like
that's going to make golfers get more
into shape
i would think anyway let's plow ahead
here
let's do some reads here um
all right oh my bookie hey how the [ __ ]
you doing all right all right get a
little action on the game
okay raise the stakes um watching any
sport
is a hell of a lot more exciting when
you got a stake in the game
god damn right i have i had 50 bucks
just 50. that's just that big money
right i had 50 bucks on that ncaa final
against
my buddy paul versi and i was up off the
couch rooting for baylor
um but anyway but regardless of why you
play
uh you need a platform that makes it
easy at mybookie.ag
alphagolf they make it easy bet mlb
regular season nba player props and
every other
major event like the highly anticipated
boxing match between
mma veteran oh god you don't want to get
a fighter's name wrong here
ben askren and youtuber jake
paul jake paul stepping up his game
fighting an mma veteran all right now
all you jake paul haters out there if he
went if he wins this
against an mma veteran last time he beat
a former nba player so they were both
you know fish out of water a youtuber
versus a former nba player now if
he beats an mma guy
former mma veteran i mean you got to
respect that right
um all right bet and get with my bookie
place a single wager
of 20 on the fight and you'll get a free
bet for ufc 261.
if that isn't enticing enough uh back to
former olympians corner and you'll get a
two for one payout
well it says two and then it's the dot
dot one payout i don't know what that
means
i never understood all of this [ __ ] uh
with
my bookie odds boost on ben askren to
win the fight outright
sign up this week at mybookie.ag
alpha golf with promo code bird to take
advantage of
a 50 bonus on your first deposit and set
yourself up with a free bet
that's promo code bird to grab yourself
a free cash bonus at mybookie.ag
uh ben askren and jake paul it's the
fight that nobody asked for
but everyone can't stop stop talking
about it's the genius of it
the genius of jake paul is he knows how
to irritate the [ __ ] out of people
and he knows that the more irritating he
is the more people are going to want to
watch him get punched in the face
and and the more money he's gonna make
old school promoter right there and you
won't want to miss out
on any of it at my bookie uh bet
anything anytime
anywhere with my bookie all right
roman everybody you know most guys have
tried different ways
to last longer but thinking about
baseball doesn't always work
uh the folks at roman and online men
health
company are changing the game with roman
swipes
the secret to longer lasting sex roman
are clinically proven way to last longer
in bed
they're effective easy to use and fast
acting but don't require prescription
roman can ship swipes to you and
discreet unmarked packaging
and each it basically they numb your
dick a little bit
is what it is they don't say this in the
copy but that's what it is you're
putting like a topical anesthetic under
your dick
all right so that the train doesn't come
a little early uh
it doesn't come in the station a little
earlier unmarked package and each swipe
swipes packet is small enough to hide in
your wallet
for whenever you need it and swipes are
great they will not transfer to your
partner
uh so you can last longer without
worrying
oh my god dude if you [ __ ] put one of
these
if you [ __ ] anesthetize your dick and
you put a condom on
you're gonna be a porn star uh swipes
are great and they will not transfer to
your partner so you can last longer
without worrying they are super easy to
use just take the swipes out of the
packet
swipe it on uh let it dry
and you're good to go that's it i'm
imagining it's it dries pretty quickly
uh go to get roman.com burr
and get if you [ __ ] use these swipes
wear a condom and think about baseball
man i'm telling you you're going to be
in the game for a while
go to get roman r-o-m-a-n-dot-com
b-u-r-r and get ten dollars off your
first order of swipes
plus free two-day shipping that's
getroman.com
burr for ten dollars off your first
order of swipes
and free two-day shipping uh sunday
lawn care talk about how great it is to
have a good lawn and care for it you
know what i live out here in a desert
so i don't really have any grass and i
will tell you this i
really miss mowing the lawn
all right that was one of my favorite i
[ __ ] love doing it
you know when i was a kid you know my
dad behind christ get out there mother
god damn lord
get in here hit the books all right dad
right
um
i used to put on my little [ __ ]
walkman right
i'd listen to my [ __ ] heavy metal i
would go out there and i would mow the
lawn
get a couple more freckles i loved it i
loved the smell of it i loved the whole
strategy that i would have where i would
i would
like i had a whole way that like a
zamboni the way i would do it
so i didn't have because you know we
didn't have like the back the bag was a
pain in the ass
because the bag would fill up quick and
then you got to stop and empty it out it
was just a [ __ ] pain in the ass so
what i would do
was you know whichever way the lawnmower
we had it blew the
[ __ ] out to the uh to the right so i
would mow
the outskirts i'd do a big [ __ ]
square where it all blew in
and then i would go down the middle
right
and i would and i would just i would
just keep doing that square in the
square
big rectangle right it would just keep
getting small and small and each time
it was blowing it to the right until i
just had this big
one long strip of grass rake it up and i
would be [ __ ] done
because if you left it out there the sun
would get on it and it would burn and
would leave these
these streak marks you know and then my
dad
ah christ it looks like [ __ ]
then you have to get out
oh my god [ __ ] hilarious guy uh
sunday lawn care all right i already
talked about it see your lawn thrive
this spring with your own custom
long custom lawn care plan for sunday
sunday is more than just a lawn care
product
um it is a custom lawn care plan with a
variety of ways to help you grow
a beautiful lawn control weeds and
remove pests
they take out all of the guesswork and
unwanted chemicals that's a good thing
so you can grow a beautiful lawn that's
better for people pets and the planet oh
speaking of which
i saw this thing on uh
you know somebody did send me this thing
i you know like not like i didn't notice
but you know bathroom products that they
test on rabbits and they're shooting
things into the eyes and burning them
with chemicals
and there was this whole list of [ __ ]
[ __ ] that was
animal friendly bathroom products if
anybody's using that stuff if you can
recommend a deodorant
in a lotion that works i'm all in
i'm all in all right enough you know
i've been a douche enough in my life so
trying to be
i'm in the back nine of my life who's
kidding who i'm probably on you know the
12th hole here
so let's [ __ ] try to be a good guy
here a little bit
uh sunday makes taking care of your lawn
easier than ever
um i just went to sunday.com i hate when
they say that
i didn't i just i'm getting this copy
now i believe in this i would like a
green lawn but i didn't just go there
but you can go to
sunday.com you put in your home address
and their free lawn analysis
will take a look of the rest all in just
seconds
uh sunday uses soil and climate data to
create a tailored nutri
what are they going to google earth my
[ __ ] house so you get all this stuff
your lawn needs and nothing it doesn't
sunday is made with ingredients that you
can actually pronounce like seaweed
iron and millet that's what i like right
here all natural [ __ ] molasses
so you can grow better and feel better
about it this is great
i'm behind this product i don't know
about that big brother [ __ ] but i like
seaweed molasses and iron
sundae explains exactly what you get and
why and everything is waiting
at your door when you need it all you
have to do is attach the ready-to-use
pouch
to a garden hose and spray
lawn care used to take up used to take
up a whole day now it only
it takes less than 15 minutes best of
all the stuff really works
and the grass looks better than ever
this is perfect everybody and it's all
natural
so you don't have to worry that you're
poisoning little [ __ ] varmints
that the birds that you eat then the
coyotes eat you [ __ ] poison the whole
food chain
good for these guys i like this and you
know something i got some of that liquid
death that comes in the aluminum
can it's great [ __ ] water and it's
made out of an aluminum can so
you can recycle it there you go i like
these products
uh let sunday take the guesswork out of
growing a greener more beautiful lawn
this spring
uh visit getsunday.com to get 20
off your custom lawn plan at checkout
that's 20
off your custom plan to uh that's
getsunday.com it's april man this is the
time to do it and it's all natural
and you won't be killing any birdies or
rabbits isn't that nice and your lawn
will be nice and green
it'll be all lush you get some hair
plugs your lawn looks like the head of
hair next thing you know the ladies are
checking you out
and you're having a good [ __ ] time
by the way i'm gonna tell you something
the most exciting [ __ ]
thing that's happened to me
in a while other than becoming a dad
okay is or the
yeah yeah that's it right
um i got the green light to get that
truck
i got the green light to get the truck
but the thing is is i have to keep my
four-door sedan because
i have kids so
i am a frugal bastard so i am not going
to buy the truck
until my vegas gig
my gig in vegas and once i see that
indoor gigs
have come back and that i can make money
on the road
i am going to build the f-250 of my
dreams
um i can't wait i if i can just find a
place where i can store it because
i don't have the [ __ ] room for it
it's the stupidest [ __ ] thing
i'm ever gonna buy um
and i bought a lot of dumb [ __ ] but i
don't give a [ __ ]
all right i figured my kids get a little
bit older
you know i can teach them how to drive
when they're young then i can get rid of
my car
and then i'll just have that [ __ ]
truck and then that [ __ ] truck
i'm done that is my ferrari that's the
[ __ ] vehicle i always wanted
order a ford f2 i don't know why i just
i was i
played with tonka trucks when i was a
kid and i just got into them and as much
as i like
cars and that type of [ __ ] i've i've
always liked trucks better
and i'm talking like every [ __ ] truck
like i i there was a wild man i was
going on the internet
and um i'm talking like delivery trucks
like i found this there was a truck it
was actually the company was
white i think it was just called white
truck or whatever
i swear to god i was like that's the
name of the company let me just look
this up
and i found like a cab with like a
chassis
and i sent it to the guy this guy that i
know that does
re builds trucks amazingly
um white truck
let's see here 10 wheeler
see if i can find it now let's
i forget the name of it because now it's
just showing up as
as the as the color it was something
white i forget what but it was just like
it was like a
from the early 70s and it just had the
cab and the chassis and i just sent him
a picture
i was like what can you do with this and
he was just like oh man i could [ __ ]
build you a sick ass ride
and i was showing it to my wife and she
was like that's stupid what were you
gonna do with it it's like
i don't know
drive down the street and feel like a
five-year-old in a sandbox
can't i have that you know
the [ __ ] chicks get to have their their
version of the kardashian walk-in closet
why can't i have my version of a [ __ ]
tonka truck uh but anyways
she gave me the green light and now i
have to push through the catholic guilt
of just buying something and doing
something for yourself you know that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i did a stand-up gig at a uh
at a methodist church and i was talking
to somebody because i was just like you
know i might take this [ __ ] being
sober thing all the way
because i used to go to church every
week but like i can't go to the catholic
church because
you know i mean of what they did to
those kids and how they looked the other
way
and now every time i feel like i'm
giving them money i'm paying for their
defense attorneys
right but uh
i don't know i might go to a methodist
thing just to see what their take on
jesus
is and even though i'm not into any of
that [ __ ] i don't believe in anybody
there's something about
going to a service once a week it's like
going to an aaa meeting for
for [ __ ] alkies it reminds you hey
you know don't [ __ ] do that like i
feel like there there is something to be
said about going to that [ __ ] oh jesus
guys are you losing me
am i am i becoming 700 club bill
relax that ain't gonna happen um
if anything i'll go there and get
material on myself
um all right let's let's read some of
the uh some of the letters from the fine
folks
out here before i put on the masters
which just [ __ ] started [ __ ]
i don't have my remote oh well i'll miss
a little bit of it all right in case you
missed it we announced the new
reschedule
uh shows last week oh this is about my
tour
yes in case you missed it we announced
some new and rescheduled shows
last week on the podcast for my fall
tour
the bill buys an f250 fall tour
and we're adding more shows second night
added at
red rocks in denver on friday october
1st i cannot [ __ ] believe
i'm gonna be performing at that venue i
have to do something
at that place to uh i have to record i
you know when you get to play a venue
like that god knows if you ever get to
come back again
so i have to document i don't know what
i'm gonna do maybe
who knows maybe do a vinyl record there
who knows who knows
um and when i'm on tour i'm going to be
bringing
my uh my uh
my madison square garden one the double
album
which dude it looks [ __ ] sick
it opens up like a vinyl album and then
in the middle is this panoramic shot i
had
the the stage was in the middle in the
round of the crowd and my little dumb
ass in the middle of it it looks [ __ ]
sick and the recording is incredible and
nobody has it yet
nobody has it yet so um
i've been trying to think of how to go
about
selling that thing uh you know maybe
amoeba records out here
you know tower records is shut down like
i don't know you know if you have a
record store or something like that
maybe we can figure something out
but um i'm gonna be selling uh
that when i'm out on tour so um
all right third show added in long beach
oh my god
at the terrace theater then that's where
richard pryor
did that special richard pryor live in
concert the concert movie
that changed stand-up comedy um i think
the two best
specials of all time are that one and
bill cosby himself
is and that is the entire gamut as far
as working totally squeaky clean
although bill cosby says [ __ ] once
and and richard pryor just being totally
raw honest the performance the whole
thing
just two masters and and that is for me
is the entire
gamut uh although there is the andy
kaufman thing too where you just go up
and try to annoy the [ __ ] out of the
crowd and read the great gatsby i don't
know
as far as [ __ ] that i related to those
were the pillars right there
um all right second night added in st
louis at the fabulous fox theater
on september 29th
uh third show added in san jose on
sunday november 7th at the san jose
center for the performing arts
uh go to billberg.com tour for tickets
and get more tour updates uh
i cannot wait to get out there in front
of you guys
and uh give you my new hour of ignorance
all right here we go here we go let's
get into what the fine folks writing in
had to say this week
um all right
thank you bill bert podcast and anything
better dear bill
the my favorite part of the week weekend
now
is to wake up saturday to a new episode
of anything better that's the one i do
with paul verzi
uh what a perfect time to post a podcast
kudos to you and paul
also the stan hope episode of bill burt
was amazing
can't wait for part two uh i think he
joined the podcast again
or even as a regular once a month guest
yeah we had
um doug stanhope um
one of the greatest comedians of all
time it's just it's a fact
and it doesn't get said enough other
than by hardcore because you got to be a
hardcore fan
fan a stand up there's a lot of people
that
um think they know stand-up comedy you
got to watch doug stanhope
um this guy is the real deal if you're
looking for somebody that is going to
say
exactly what the [ __ ] he's thinking and
does not give a [ __ ] about the
fallout this is the comedian for you and
he has been that guy ever since i first
met him in the late 90s when he had the
long hair and i had the orange afro
way back in the day when we look like
extras on
[ __ ] barney miller um
he is the [ __ ] man so he did yeah he
did
uh episode of bill burt this week and
then the anything better podcast with
paul versi
this is what i did during the pandemic
was basically i
you know it was a way for me to connect
with uh comics that i hung out with but
didn't get to see
i'm starting to do podcasts with them
and i'm having a great time doing it so
check them out if you can
all right fatty here hey uh little billy
longstocking
uh to the butt hurt fatty that you
emailed you last week as a fat person
myself
i find your take on the subject
hilarious
well thank you because i'm not against
you i'm rooting for you
you know but i i my job is to make fun
of [ __ ] so you know that is that is what
it is
he said if slash wen or he or she said
this a joke hits close to home that's
because
of my own insecurities and the truth
that you're telling
if anything you're motivating us fatties
to make better decisions
and the ones that take offense need to
waddle to a mirror and take a look yeah
that's what's hilarious it's like what
i'm doing
is not fatal what they're doing is fatal
um if you're pale freckled red face
can improve why can't i
yeah dude if i can try to yeah if i can
become better at something look at the
way i look yeah exactly that gives
everybody hope anyway
this person says i'm gonna start this
30-day increment
deal you do and bite off small chunks
until i'm a less fatter [ __ ] um
i'll laugh at you ridiculing the
majority of society while i do it
including the butthurt fatty that
emailed their complaint
while sobbing through another half
gallon of bluebell
uh go [ __ ] yourself well there you go
that's the attitude it's the attitude
you gotta [ __ ] have
um and good luck to you sir or ma'am i
am rooting for you and i'm even rooting
for the [ __ ]
sad fatty who [ __ ] emailed me last
week
sorry trying to stay hydrated here uh
your desire to stay fit
is privilege oh god oh please please
with your flat screen tv tell me how
privileged
my flat screen thing is oh god are they
going to say the obvious thing that in
starving countries that
just getting nutrition this is gonna oh
my god this i'm gonna
have to grip my teeth through this dear
bill i'm writing to inform you
that your journey to fitness is racist
and privilege laden
oh i thought it was because i was an old
dad and i had a responsibility that i
was gonna bring kids into the world
in late life as i did to stick around
long enough to raise them so they're not
bad people
the ability to be a specific form or
size is inherently determined
by what you find attractive in yourself
well i'm not smart enough for that
sentence let me try to slow down
the ability to be a specific form or
size is inherently determined by what
you find attractive in yourself
i suppose you've dated women from
cold countries that require
weight for survival well i grew up in
the east coast and we had nor'easters
uh it's easy with the colonial
perspective you how god here's all the
buzzwords the colonial perspective
you have to not see this oh well thank
you for
for squeegeeing my third eye oh genius
you wouldn't last in the chandra where
my grandparents grew up
they were not skinny germans like
yourself
were strong and had pride oh wait a
second
so are you saying germans aren't strong
and don't have
pride now didn't you call me racist
earlier
uh when you mentioned being bald as a
negative feature
you were insulting the very weak genes
your race has
look at this this is the classic uh this
is the classic woke liberal being
reverse
well not everybody who's german is bald
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's called having a sense of humor
about yourself please consider this
and make changes to your life
accordingly
oh my god i mean that has just stuck the
landing for [ __ ]
pompous impressed with yourself liberal
[ __ ] yeah well
all right wow wow that was that wow that
was a clap of thunder wasn't it
okay anyway yeah i'm sure that's why
they survived up there because they were
fat
[ __ ] acting like they're [ __ ]
walruses
i think dressing warmly you know and not
putting all that extra burden on your
heart
is probably a better way to survive but
evidently yes
i'm not a i'm not a fat [ __ ] cause i
can't stop eating cookies
i'm just trying to stay warm all right
yeah that was that was mind-blowing
um advice
uh please consider this and make changes
to your life accordingly oh my god i
mean just like
the the [ __ ] i am a lefty and i am i
cannot [ __ ] believe
maybe it always existed just under the
surface and that's what the people the
red side was always pointing out
but uh i guess i guess the left has
always been really [ __ ]
self-congratulatory no but the the right
does it too if you ever listen to ted
nugent there's another tip from your old
uncle ted
like yes the whole [ __ ] thing figured
out
what a way to go through life
i always thought i consciously said how
[ __ ] stupid i am into this that's how
i thought i was
maybe someday i could reach this
person's uh
level of [ __ ] i don't know what
wokeness i don't even know what that was
that's just one of those things you know
when you run into a person like that you
say yeah you just
the best thing you just agree with them
oh okay is that how it works okay
just let them walk off feeling like they
did something um
anyway advice
um by the way can more people like that
please write in
um advice hey bill [ __ ] love your
podcast bro
uh been a fan for years through your
stand-ups and movies etc i have an issue
bill
i myself am black and i'm dating a white
woman oh jesus why would you do that
who has an interracial child
uh parenthesis not a problem okay
the problem is the way her kid behaves
i was just [ __ ] with the white chick
thing by the way okay the problem is
the way her kid behaves i was brought up
in the whoop your kids
era uh that we as a society have
forgotten yeah i don't think you want to
do that you don't do that
the kid is four and seems to get away
with murder talking back
acting out the whole nine you know
i really like this woman but she seems
to get upset when
i mention anything about her kid's
behavior
like it's normal or some [ __ ] i wasn't
brought up that way
so his behavior bothers me just thinking
about his behavior is bothering me too
so should i stick it out and just deal
with it or should i say
[ __ ] that and move on uh thanks for
listening and stay funny
hope i hear this on your podcast your
ginger bastard
um i say you say [ __ ] it and move on
because if i think you really had
feelings for this woman
that would have come up and you would
have said you know i really like this
person i'm really i love her i'm really
into her
i this is just something that i'm just
worried is going to be you didn't say
any of that you're just like yeah i'm
dating this white
broad she's got an interracial kid not a
problem
okay but as far as if you do decide to
stick around
okay you don't need to hit kids you
should never hit kids that's not a good
way to do it
you just have to remember the kid's four
and can't reach the food
so you have all the power all right i'm
not saying starving either i'm just
using that as an example that you are
totally controlling the environment
but if you're dealing with this woman
who you you know
sounds like you're having a good time
banging her but i don't
see like you're into her um but if it if
it moves on to another level then uh
at the very least the kid has to respect
you and you can do that
without raising your voice you can do
that without inflicting pain you can do
it without starving them
but you just you just don't tolerate it
like you know when they start whining
and crying
you just you don't even address it let
them have that little hissy fit
flip out and then whatever they hissy
fitting and flipping out about you still
don't give them
and then just say to them like why would
i give you whatever they tell you i want
an ice cream why would i give you ice
cream after you just behave like that
because i wanna yes yeah
yeah you're not you're never going to
get ice cream when you behave like that
and that's how it is now you can go deal
with that now and go flip out and throw
yourself on the couch i don't give a
[ __ ]
okay you're not strong enough to open
the fridge so you're not getting it
until you behave the way you need to be
behaving
um so that's what i do if you stick
around but i mean just the way you wrote
about her
i would i would move on uh
all right masturbating or cheating hey
bill burrington
uh burnington raincoat factory
um burlington coat factory i got it
oh burlington you did have the l in
there i couldn't see it hey
billy burlington coat factory raincoat
factory
uh for your love of raincoats over
umbrellas
oh i love a raincoat um i live in
florida
and to me a man who uses either
is a little limp-wristed oh yeah you got
those steel
balls hanging off the back of your truck
um
but that is an old-school guy think that
if you actually dress for the weather
that makes you a [ __ ] you always have
to act like it's a nice
spring day uh but moving on to ask your
advice
i've been waiting with i've been with my
fiance for eight years now
and even before dating i had become
bored with regular
regularly watching porn online
masturbation
so one day 10 years ago i discovered
online dating sites oh boy
and started to talk to women i met
online on the phone
sorry and it would eventually
what the hell is it led to phone sex
ever since then masturbating by myself
is uninteresting and unfulfilling
i've continued this practice since being
exclusive with my current fiance and was
wondering
if it's considered cheating uh that's
always an easy question if you told her
you were doing this
how would she react i never used my real
name
and haven't updated my picks since
initially signing up 10 years ago
and never met any of the women offline i
use them for phone sex
as long as possible and then when they
want to move things further along i
stopped speaking to them
i've never cheated on any previous
girlfriends in my life and was wondering
your thoughts on this thanks in advance
p.s i love the podcast and go [ __ ]
yourself yeah talk to a therapist
talk to a therapist one of the problems
that is developed
in this age of technology yeah you're
addicted to phone sex
and yeah in you know i had like a porn
addiction
that i had just i finally realized hey
i'm [ __ ] doing this all the time
this is how you know you're addicted to
porn if you try to jerk off
with just your thoughts and if you can't
make it happen you got a [ __ ] problem
that needs to be addressed
so i would talk to a professional and
just say you have a problem
and i would nip this in the in the bud
is that how you say it i always forget
butt or bud nip it in the bud and just
[ __ ]
uh um
handle this [ __ ] before you get married
because living a life like that is gonna
wear on you and you're gonna feel like a
piece of [ __ ]
so um i wouldn't do that i mean how
would you like it if she was doing that
would you consider that not cheating you
know
of course you would what you're doing is
wrong um
so i i would talk to i would go to a
therapist and talk to him and they will
[ __ ]
help it out and you don't need to be
embarrassed they have heard every
[ __ ] thing
in the world and what you have here is
like
is like a misdemeanor compared to what
the [ __ ] they hear every goddamn day and
they'll help you through it
and you'll you'll be back to being a
really
sort of a normal person because this
whole [ __ ] thing jerking off using
technology
is is if you really think about it is
goes against the laws of nature because
it did not exist
for 99 of the time that human beings
have been on earth
and i feel like we are all the lab rats
of it right now
and um i feel like
in the future people are going to be way
more careful
about what they watch way more careful
about
everything and way more like monitoring
it
we're back in the day you know you had a
bottle of scotch in the bottom
[ __ ] desk drawer you know mayor i was
married tyler moore she'd come in oh mr
grant should be all upset and he'd
[ __ ] pour her a drink
he did that today that'd be the end of
your [ __ ] career so
um you know this [ __ ] is just sort of
like you know when cocaine first came
out doctors said it was no more
addicting than caffeine
and then a bunch of people ruined their
lives over it so don't ruin your life
over this you got a great
person that you want to marry you owe it
to them and yourself go to a therapist
work it out
i think you'll be fine um all right
advice on divorced parents
uh dear billy nia's
box breaker oh jesus uh love your comedy
and hope things
are well with nia and the kids i have a
problem i could use some advice with my
father divorced my mother after 18 years
of marriage
i was 9 years old i'm 23 now my father
told us
he left her for the way she approached
parenting
so she'd yell when trying to get us
to do something and other examples i
won't get into my mother believes my
father cheated on her and left
this might be true since he entered a
relationship immediately after filing
for divorce you know it's usually a red
flag
but i honestly don't know since then
i've been
i've been great i've built great
relationships with both
and loved them very much here's my
problem during the divorce my father
claims my mother took a substantial
amount of ammunition and ammunition
loading components
he manufactures his own ammos out of
spent casings
which are valued very light very highly
especially now during the pandemic my
father always mentioned wanting to get
it all back
i'd like to see it return since both my
father and i are avid shooters and it's
something we've bonded over
while i never seen this stuff at my
mother's place after she
sold the original house i wouldn't put a
pastor to have taken it
i just don't know how to bring it up to
my mother without starting any problems
or causing any drama
during the divorce things got very
heated with both parents fine
divorce orders restraining orders on
each other
at one point first my dad wasn't allowed
to see my sister and i for three months
and my mother wasn't allowed to see us
for a month any advice you can give me
on how to approach this would be greatly
appreciated all right dude i would stay
out of it
i'd stay out of it i mean if that's how
the divorce went down and you're talking
ammunition and guns
i would [ __ ] stay out of that that is
an easy one
um just stay out of it just listen to
your dad yep that sucks
maybe someday you know she'll come
around but do not
insert yourself in you know it's not
your
fault that they got divorced it's not
your fault that they handled the divorce
the way they did
it's not your fault your mother did or
didn't take the [ __ ] you're not a gum
shoe
it's not your f it's not your job dude
just don't be taking on
other people's [ __ ] problems even if
they're your parents let them work that
[ __ ] out
and considering they're very volatile
people there's whole [ __ ] things with
guns and ammos and [ __ ] i would just
leave it alone that's what i would do
all right rhythms of comedy what's up
what's up pinky
i like that because that works in an
obvious way and then also you know i'm a
liberal lefty so you might think i'm a
commie i like all of that what's up
pinky that's hilarious
uh this clip of uh mark norman's stand
up
to a drummer is bananas yeah i love when
people are able to do that i also love
mark norman he's amazing i just want
you to know i just want to know what you
think of it i'm recently i'm a recent
fan
of the show and laugh hard every episode
go [ __ ] yourself
i guess that's what cool kids say um
i'll tell you something else there's a
comedian out there
uh greg hahn who's [ __ ] unbelievable
and then i watched him on the bob and
tom show playing drums he's a [ __ ]
beast uh there's a lot of drama uh
comedians that play drums greg hahn
is [ __ ] right up there man he was
crushing it
um all right that is it that is the
podcast i'll let you know on thursday
how my second shot of onsen
goes i'll talk to you see ya